in that previous episode wedding the
better right no Paco here fella
get low yeah are you absolutely certain
this is why I like a genuine lives I
don't know he's awesome
ah [ __ ] that son of a [ __ ]
- getting away I missed one there's no
way that was because I Parkash you
miscounted vodka rocks I tore it off
during the fight
- receipts from the same gas station
interesting
you're not the origami killer Ethan I
can prove it Seana still leaving shawn
is all that matters now
yes sir
yeah oh this our jacket I get it yeah -
II all this time and I had no idea
you're pretty good Nora [ __ ]
journalist actually she wasn't even I I
wanted to tell you but I was afraid that
you'd asked me to go and when it's all
over I won't be with you that's all
right even if I don't have an it worried
forget he doesn't like it what is doing
it I'm sorry Ethan how's it going red my
name is Ferrara pie welcome back to
another who found them probably one of
the last episodes of heavy rain why are
you going out Madison we need to get up
and get down put him here um Madison is
gonna get some I don't know what she's
doing right now I don't know why this is
anything to do with the story but hey I
guess we're gonna find out I I thought
I'd are you in love medicine I think I'm
starting to fall
the guy with no nipple what a disgrace
find his son and prove he's innocent
what the cops I'll be able to help him
matatini why didn't they recognize her
des hey calm down
looking for Ethan it looks like a raid
oh [ __ ] oh she's gonna sneak in okay
let's do that
there's no Buena
excuse me hang on is this great like
being in a TV show
I'm sure who'd have thought it the
origami killer renting a room here he
registered under a false name but I
recognized his face oh sure
all right I don't have time for your
[ __ ] come on what was the damn
number uh 207 come on come on pick up
the phone oh uh uh the cops they're in
the motel is fine here I hate it I
wonder what happened if it's not him I
mean if it's the wrong oh [ __ ] Ethan
your [ __ ] ha ha
we cannot fail our bras we came so far
to save our son we're not gonna what
Ethan you're [ __ ] you for it that's
okay
Hey Ezio man for a guy oh hello can't we
go in there oh sorry dude ah [ __ ] I was
sound like he doesn't know how to open
the door
left that was let his left down no I'm
supposed to go up I'm stupid yeah go up
I remember that what nice going Ethan
he's good
good check him for not having a finger
or a nipple Oh Ben what are you doing
you're crazy
slalom like a mother ha ha
should we shoot him I know this a and
they should have shown what [ __ ] okay
that was open
I'm healed we're gonna go ahead get down
holy [ __ ] they're closed one of the
desks should or not I wanna hug him
that guy's gonna get fired
stop please I suck at this
well even got helicoptering anything
even your [ __ ] just deal with it ah
nah
damn man now let it go
it's around
surrender or jump jump [ __ ] yeah haha
are you crazy
it's crazy you should have died there
a.m. get up Ethan Jesus
what if just [ __ ] children if he's a
mass murderer what am i Ethan don't mess
around oh that's right you don't open
the door I need to save my son
that's right what you gonna do about it
that guy
I lost my god poor man he doesn't give a
[ __ ] about there anything why not just
sit down on the ground yep Scotch al
baiy why not more eat then
I'm so confused by this ending because I
didn't get this part of the some parts
at least I did changes scenes they don't
even a car that's pretty cool at least
pretty sure this occurred though
Lord I'm sorry Scott you should have
listened to me mr. Shelby huh I told you
to drop the investigation your son is a
serial killer just remember that does he
have to kill before you turn him in
Gordie has his faults but he's still my
son
you have no children mr. Shelby you
can't possibly understand you leave me
no choice your investigation is over oh
good
are they out for good is he gonna kill
me
Wow
they Callahan
we woulda thought Lauren Lauren is a
ship
whoa we're [ __ ]
Lauren Lauren wake up oh [ __ ]
we're gonna say Lauren I think you can
choose to save her I'm not sure but I
want to save her
oh really all right
what are you gonna do with that oh okay
I guess that's that works
damnit
Mama's not doctor done cut loose you
don't have this time one of the discs
use proper ropes next time Jesus Christ
save Lauren man
yeah you better secure saving born
Lauren Lauren wake up
Lauren
yeah we're saving her
for sure I'm not leaving without you
Lauren we love each other we just don't
know it yet
Oh shucks whoa this is no bueno
slap her just for fun
the shop this isn't this literally
impossible because of the pressure I
don't think that's possible but hey
that's just my opinion
thanks going Scott shouting you
disobeyed best six
only Scott Shelby can do that always got
y'all
plue-sama she lives
yes yes awesome she died the last time
for me I was gonna take up swimming
again
wow this is shitty what I had in mind we
got a car back at your place
mine's obviously pretty [ __ ] up yeah
sure what are you gonna do I'm gonna go
settle a few scores Oh Scott Shadow pay
yours Madam's we don't let anybody in
but me
okay Oh careful Scott
she doesn't want to live it ah
Scot Shelby has some business
hahaha that's a nice achievement right
there well look at that that's the face
of someone who wants to [ __ ] [ __ ] up
Oh step on the gas
none
with a piece-of-shit car
all right you go sketchy all day you
work it right on it thank you better
moving wrong here Oh
whoa oh that's one down okay Wow sketch
show much all right
later [ __ ] you too [ __ ]
Holly [ __ ] YouTube it kills on the news
ah didn't I what you do best
did you [ __ ] me chills everyone
damn got Shelby's good looking at you
[ __ ] with Scott Shelby then think that
six gone oh yes I got it together her
little [ __ ]
where's wanna [ __ ] with scotch elevate
hello bad mo [ __ ] why do they fly like
that it's stupid
alright anyone else Yuto fine I don't
give a [ __ ] each alright so next station
Lily don't you hear me
crusher son of a [ __ ] please [ __ ]
[ __ ]
get a kid Lauren man [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
your idiot son killed all those kids
didn't he he's the origami killer
no no he's innocent he's got a killer
not a killer
my which way Hey you obviously are yeah
a [ __ ] liar now tell me the truth
No No please don't hurt me last chance
I don't know I swear I don't know
anything
stop stop okay guys it's time I don't I
don't want to do everything
lordy Lordy always wanted his fun you
know he wanted to to be like the origami
killer ah he kidnapped that kitten he
held him under the water for a little
too long it was an accident an
unfortunate accident he just wanted to
play he told me everything
he was crying he was so sorry for what
had happened whatever he did good Ian
Gordy is my son ah damn that's [ __ ] up
man
no one will miss him no but why was that
that boy Gordy killed no one will miss
him the street trash like so many others
ah you disgusting pilot [ __ ] you man
what is it John Sheppard what about John
Sheppard why did you put flowers on his
eye I own the construction site where he
died why does he care about him and not
the other one I've been putting flowers
on his grave for 30 years
my wife wins round there what happened
to him I don't know he was adopted I
think his mother
his mother should know her name is Anne
Antron Shepard
Oh
we will see his mother my heart my heart
quickly I need my pills get draw there
not today not today
Shelby come back [ __ ] party you come
back can't order me what what is he
doing
you see that he's flying in the air
I think that's the right decision I mean
I wouldn't have killed him if I had like
a gun but I don't know he tried to kill
us so I don't see a reason to save him
I'm not gonna replay this don't worry
invisible Scott because we got all of
them I guess see Madison is already
ahead of him
hello I'm looking for an shepherds room
please sign the visitors book fine are
you a member of the family
yeah you could say that Oh she'll be
pleased to have a visitor
no one ever comes to see her with the
Oscars she has trouble remembering
things but it'll still please her you
know it's rule 19 at the end of the
quarter
thank you all right
suppressing so the room at the end of
the door what's she doing stick one of
these just like just like in the game
where they dad I can't talk this is
weird but my voice is still that her
nope
only a few hours left before Shaun Mars
dies interesting my time what are you
doing
room 19 where is that I don't know girl
that's what we're looking for I think
it's over here yeah
hello Mrs Shepard is it time for my
pills already Oh Mrs Shepard I then
never on time with my pills I don't know
what they do here yeah I guess little
engine building there smiling man oh my
name is Madison Paige I'm a journalist
I'd like to ask you some questions about
your son I don't like this hospital the
food isn't very good you know
this woman might be the origami killer's
mother must be some way to get her to
remember okay
so now we can look at this origami bug
now come on it's not a coincident that
this is here so let's fold some origami
I think you need to do the dog I'm not
sure let's try
uh-huh
and that's how you do it oh you know how
to do these little dogs - yeah I love
dying my children loved origami your
children huh how to do it don't love the
little dogs
uh-huh I always wanted to call him max
max max max Oh dogs with the same name I
was wasting my time telling him they
couldn't all have the same name ha ha ha
he always wanted his paper dogs max max
it's funny isn't it no can you process
can't be a coincidence
are these your children mrs. Shepperd
John and his brother is that them they
are good little boys nothing
their father never looked after them
always drinking they didn't have an easy
life you know I cried when they told me
ah here we go
I'd already lost one of my children and
now they were taking away another one
you understand yeah forgot the foster
family Mrs Shepard what was the name of
the foster family that adopted John's
brother there were really very nice
people I met them you know in the
beginning I used to go and see my little
boy and then I got sick and I couldn't
go any longer perhaps he thought I'd
forgotten him ah he must have thought I
didn't love him anymore
that's sad it's really sad his name Mrs
Shepard what was his name
but I loved him if you only knew how
much I missed him please and his name
Madison come on
come closer come closer
oh come on no you don't whisper it huh
Madison by that reaction I can tell that
it the killer is son of a [ __ ] I didn't
know actually that why did she had to
whisper not cool not cool all right I'm
sorry I'm sorry I gotta have that is
episode 8 he's going on to put your life
my comparative ginge ID in the next
episode we'll hopefully finally [ __ ]
find out [ __ ] fail our friends sounds
but you know I love it
you